you don't think i'm some crazy old girl
for doing this
i mean i say all that it is time to step
out of the mainstream and celebrate some
of the most exciting and innovative
names in filmmaking
today so we're gonna break down five
breakout black directors right now
on the ketchup all this month and beyond
be sure to go to rottentomatoes.com and
check out our black history month hub
which is
all kinds of guides and articles
including our list of 15
up-and-coming black directors and today
we're looking at a handful from that
list
starting with shaka king and judas and
the black messiah
now the tale of judas betraying jesus is
as old as well
at least the bible but not since the
assassination of jesse james by the
coward robert ford has there been a film
that
so humanizes a historical villain enter
judas and the black messiah currently
sitting at 99
on the tomato meter shakka king takes
the tragic story of black panther
chairman fred hampton
who on december 4th 1969 was shot in his
bed
during a pre-morning raid organized by
the fbi and chicago police
the film is told from the perspective of
william o'neill a petty criminal turned
informant who
infiltrated the panthers and directly
led to the raid that killed hampton
starring daniel kaluuya lakeith
stanfield and jesse plemons judas marks
a departure from king's roots and tv
sitcoms like shrill
and people of earth but it is a powerful
one according to slate critic
karen hahn it doesn't feel like a
stretch to name it one of 2021's best
films
judas and the black messiah is a
powerful calling card for shaka king
and you can actually check it out in
theaters or on hbo max on february 12th
it is a straight-up crime that more
people haven't seen
stella and the spain tioresha pose
genre-bending high school mob drama that
feels like the love child of meme girls
and good fellas
its release in april unfortunately
coincided with covet lockdown but that's
no excuse to sleep on it
like ryan johnson's brick stella takes
the tropes of a gangster drama and maps
it onto the doggy dog world of high
school hierarchies
currently certified fresh at 88 on the
tomato meter
stella tells the story of an elite east
coast boarding school run by competing
students
she must find and groom her replacement
as the head of her faction the spades or
risk
disrupting the drug field ecosystem
hiding behind the curtain of a tony prep
school
poe's ingenious world building never got
the widespread
credit that it deserved although a
review from the rap praised the feature
debut as having quote a style all its
own
spare but rich and able to make the
umpteenth teen movie we've all seen
feel fresh now if you missed it the
first time we've got some good news it
is available to stream on
amazon and the streaming service
actually tapped poe to make her debut an
original series
very exciting i mean if you got a
problem with it well
honestly that's that's your problem even
if you don't know the name
blitz bazawule you know his work trust
us
basule is one of the directors behind
arguably the highlight of summer 2020
beyonce's visual album black is king
inspired by the lion king black is king
debuted on disney plus in july and is
certified fresh at 95 percent on the
tomato meter
critics didn't just like basilulle's
collaboration with queen b
they worshipped it i mean some reviews
were so effusive they became art
themselves like this one in the
telegraph which
opened with and there we were thinking
the stage recording of hamilton was
going to be the best thing on disney
plus
fools bassali's debut feature the burial
of kojo was released in 2019 on netflix
through ava duvernay's array productions
it's about a young girl in ghana
struggling with memories of her father's
tragic death
and it might not sound very netflix and
chill but bazawule's unique aesthetic
created a visual language for the
story's magical realism and it currently
sits at a hundred percent on the tomato
meter what's next after working with
beyonce well if you're basil
it's adapting the broadway musical
version of the color purple for the big
screen in 2023
no big deal who are you
we are obsessed with radablank the
playwright behind the 40 year old
version and that is version not the
steve carell movie
blank's a natural au tear with a
distinct vision
having written directed and starred in
her first feature film
shot in black and white version is part
autobiography and part
manifesto a scathing satire of the new
york theater scene's hypocritical and
self-congratulatory approach to black
playwrights who are then discarded for
not being black enough
blank stars is one of these playwrights
who decides to make a minor career
change to spit rhymes as an emcee
because if there's one industry that's
known to embrace older women
it's hip hop blank earned rave reviews
as well as major awards at sundance with
one critic calling the film a refreshing
unpretentious and often hilarious take
on middle-aged black womanhood
it's certified fresh at 98 on the tomato
meter and is streaming right now
on netflix ignore the 40 old version at
your own risk because it is what all the
cool film kids and adults will be
talking about as blank
continues to make waves why my skin's so
dry
why am i yawning right now why them aarp
gets sent to my house last but certainly
not least is janitzka bravo whose
upcoming zola gets the award for most
hyped adaptation of a twitter thread
ever zola premiered in january of 2020
at sundance where it was nominated for a
grand jury award
and it currently sits at 89 on the
tomato meter the rest of us will have to
wait till a24
june release date to see this dizzying
bio dramedy that honestly gives the
florida project and spring breakers a
run for their drug money
starring taylor page and riley keough
zola is the story of a detroit waitress
who strikes up a friendship with a
stripper named jessica over their shared
love of pole dancing
and ends up running to florida for a
two-day bender of drugs prostitution
and murder you know florida stuff
bravo's unique directorial resume
includes lemons with
ex-husband brett gilman as well as the
juneteenth episode of atlanta
she's mainly known for her experimental
festival shorts one of which was a
live-action
virtual reality experience filmed all on
a gopro
so appropriately zola is 82 minutes long
the hollywood reporter
says it makes hustlers look like a
disney movie veering adroitly between
sparkly humor and lynchy and weirdness
and honestly you can't ask for a better
recommendation than that
so mark your calendars because zola
debuts on june 30th
you want to hear a story about how me
and this [ __ ] here fell out
alright friends well that about wraps it
up but be sure to head on over to
rottentomatoes.com to check out our full
list of 15
up-and-coming black directors to look
out for in 2021 and if you have a
suggestion for us
and everyone watching right now please
leave it in the comment section also
don't forget to check out our podcast
rotten tomatoes is wrong
new episodes drop every thursday and we
know you just can't get enough of us
and if you don't want to miss out on any
future episodes of this show be sure to
hit that subscribe button and
notification bell and as always can't
thank you enough for watching the
ketchup
mi nombre is naz perez and we'll see you
guys next time
[Music]
bye
you